admittedly in the universal logo at the
beginning of this movie I was like
alright that was pretty cool happy
deathday so happy deathday is a movie
directed by the director of well you
know he starts Jessica Roth she plays a
sorority student named tree whose
parents were clearly hippie she wakes up
in the dorm room after a party it's her
birthday she goes about her day at night
she gets killed by someone wearing the
mask of the school mascot that looks
like a baby Herman head then after she's
killed she wakes up a little confused
was about the day so it's one of those
you really the same day over and over
and over again all the Groundhog Day
edge of tomorrow sometimes what it is I
know what you did last summer meets
Groundhog Day and sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't
it tries to be like you know what you
did last summer a scream slasher flick
from the nineties kind of thing about
that as those movies had a threat there
was a killer a prowler on the loose a
predator no one knew where he was coming
from no one knew who he's gonna go after
next scream implemented a curfew woods
borough had a curfew folks and was
necessary made it feel more real people
are killing people in towns that's what
happened people are killing people on
campus that's absolutely what would
happen thing is the only one who knows
about it is her because every time she
gets killed today reset she relives the
day and no one but her remembers the
events so as the slasher flick it's
trying to be it kind of falls flat
because it's not really about that it's
more about her reliving the same day and
so you have a formula you've seen a few
times before every movie that does this
does exactly what this movie does so
really confuse the first day kind of
annoyed the second day it might a third
day you get the montage and the main
plot is her trying to figure out who the
killer is which right there I feel like
I could have that solved day one all
right well day two loop to the first day
it happens she's face to face with this
dude because she doesn't know it's
actually a killer and the killer kills
her it's not about day two or three just
be like alright clearly if I die I'm
going to relive this day so just relive
the day like you did the first day when
you're face-to-face with the killer just
lift the mask be like I know who you are
there when you wake up you're like I
know who it is but you're gonna figure
that out it's easy to throw away one of
your lives to solve the murder so the
movie tries to be two different types of
movies and half succeeds at BO just like
a Roth the lead can we talk about her
for a second whatever this film's flaws
are Jessica Roth is hands down the
greatest thing in this movie she's
really good I just like her character I
like her attitude I liked her delivery
she brought this role to life without
her in this movie this movie would
probably be a bit unwatchable or at the
very least unmemorable
remember this movie simply because of
her she's gonna have a snarky little
dick at the beginning but she's kind of
cool and you like her and as the movie
progresses she progresses and the point
is she's what you latch on to she did a
really good job this dialogue she has
with somebody and it is actually a
really well delivered heartfelt
monologue yeah that's a dialogue and
monologue was really a monologue to a
person so as much as that sounds like
dialogue is really a monologue the point
is I'm pretty sure I heard sniffles in
the auditorium it's really good good for
her she could just phone it in be like
all right we're gonna do a slasher flick
sure but you can tell she just made the
most of it guys in the end happy death
day is two premises that you've seen a
lot of times before and they merge them
together to make them kind of feel like
something new doesn't really have the
memorable killer you thought it was
gonna have like after scream one I was
like they're gonna be a scream two after
this one I don't feel like there can be
a happy deathday to that's a couple of
moments of intrigue Jessica Roth
completely makes the movie but carries
the whole thing on her shoulders there
is enjoyment in here for sure possibly
with the right help so I will say happy
deathday enjoyable enough but would be
better if you're drunk
ya know right guys so happy deathday
have you seen it what did you think
about it or what's a movie out there
that does that relive the same day over
and over and over again that's not
Groundhog Day or edge of tomorrow or
live die repeat it's the same thing I
feel like this more I just can't think
of it so whatever it is whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you
[Music]